[Musique]
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
carte ya une frontière une frontière
qu'il n'y a pas de douaniers ya une
frontière où il n'y a pas de police elle
frontière on n'a pas de besoin de
passeport pour passer en revanche c'est
une frontière vraiment forte en créer
dans notre pays en créer dans notre
économie en créer dans tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on entreprend ci ont alors
essayé de deviner chacun qu'elle peut
être cette frontière est bien dans la
partie est
il y a douze salles de cinéma c'est pas
beaucoup me adou salles de cinéma dans
la partie rouge en à 0 voilà une des
frontières qui quitte une frontière
culturelle
si on prend
le taux de chômage le taux de chômage
des jeunes et le double dans le côté
rouge que dans le côté blanc si on prend
le nombre d'entreprises
on est à l'avenant et cetera etc c'est
une frontière qui est en train de
détruire notre pays c'est une frontière
qui fait qu'il y a des gens qui arrivent
et des gens qui arrivent pas c'est une
frontière ou quand on est né du mauvais
côté eh bien on a n'a pas de chance on
n'a pas de succès on a moins on part
avec des boules et on part avec un un
problème dès la naissance
[Musique]
donc elle a à la fois des limites c'est
une frontière économique
c'est une frontière où il n'y a pas
d'égalité de chances et à moins de
médecins il ya moins de chu ya moins de
d'internet il ya moins d'infrastructures
et nous regardons tous cette frontière
et on se dit bon cette frontière est là
elle est en train de deux nominés ça
fait des années qu'elle est ici ça fait
des années qu'elle nous contemplent et
la question c'est maintenant que l'on
sait que cette frontière est là on sait
que cette frontière existe qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est pas très facile qu'est ce qu'on
fait
alors il ya des gens qui ont trouvé la
solution c'est de dire regardons
ailleurs
pourquoi regarder ça ignorons que la
frontière existe et tout va bien donc le
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas un problème
qui résiste à la création d'une
commission ou à l'ignorance ou à l'autre
solution c'est de dire ça me révolte
je veux partir je vais partir je vais
partir en syrie je vais partir peut-être
en prenant un bateau je vais émigrer
soit soit dans un avion soit dans un
bateau soit dans un radeau mais je vais
faire je vais je vais tenter ma chance
ailleurs
on peut dire aussi c'est la sphère des
politiques
après tout on a participé à des
élections après tout on a à été
électeurs après tout on a une démocratie
nous pouvons dire c'est une affaire qui
nous concerne pas c'est la sphère des
politiques mais nous pouvons aussi dire
c'est notre affaire
c'est quelque chose qui nous qui nous
concerne est une des solutions c'est de
dire on va se mettre à faire des choses
pour les autres est une fondation c'est
quelque chose qui est dire je crée un
organisme de créer une structure et
cette structure elle va travailler pour
les autres alors la fondation tunisie
pour développement dont j'ai été
l'initiateur à la plusieurs programmes
mais je vous en parlais je vais vous
parler d'un de ses programmes phares qui
pourrait permettre de créer un pont avec
cette tunisie oublié qui pourrait
permettre de traverser cette frontière
sans son passeport et son papier et ce
projet c'est un peu ce programme c'est
un programme qui s'appelle elif et qui
vise les 10 points que vous voyez sur la
carte des points en noix et qu'il dit et
qui consiste à créer quoi à créer des
oeuvres de technologie et d'autres
d'entrepreneuriat des maisons de des
ponts des des stations d'égalité des
chances des stations où on peut aller
trouver ce qu'on trouve dans le côté
blanc de la tunisie dans le côté côtier
je pense que vous avez vous connaissez
tous vers la tunisie où si vous le
connaissez pas vous avez entendu parler
quand vous allez dans ce côté sombre du
pays
et bien quand vous allez à la valise est
qui et qui donne des cours
d'informatique
il n'ya pas d'ordinateur en libre
service il n'y a pas de wifi donc vous
voyez étudier l'informatique sans wifi
sans ordinateur ces prêts challenging et
donc nous essayons de changer cet état
de fait
c'est une contribution pour que cette
chose-là change et qu'on ait enfin qu'on
puisse étudier l'informatique est passé
aux travaux pratiques
sinon on fait comme les curés quand il
parle de sexualité
et eux voilà à quoi ça va ressembler ces
centres le premier sera assez bien vous
voyez c'est assez beau c'est assez joli
il ya une double peau et cette double
peau elle permet de faire un bâtiment
écologique
donc nous allons essayé d'associer la
responsabilité sociale avec la
responsabilité environnementale et que
ça soit pas une gabegie en termes
d'énergie une kadji en termes de de
ressources pour notre pays
ça ressemblera à tous les incubateurs à
tous les hommes du monde
ça sera un endroit sympathique on pourra
venir on pourra passer du temps on
pourra boire un café on pourra pas fumer
on pourra apprendre
on pourra y avoir accès à une librairie
à une bibliothèque on pourra surfer sur
internet on peut se former on peut créer
une entreprise
on peut penser à la création
d'entreprise on peut participer à
égalité avec tout le monde
à l'avenir de ce pays
donc est ce qu'il y aura là dedans il y
aura des lapins imprimante 3d
il y aura des ordinateurs il y aura des
machines laser
il y aura ce que on trouve de manière
dont tous les pays du monde
accessible aux jeunes il y aura des
espaces événements conférences notre
grand modèle c'est le grand maître de
cette cérémonie
au cem donc nous allons faire en sorte
nous allons nous greffer sur la
locomotive caussels et faire en sorte
qu' il n'y ait pas que les gens qui vont
chez les écologistes qui ont profité
mais que tous les autres puissent en
profiter également et il y aura aussi un
espace pour les entrepreneurs y aura un
espace pour ceux qui ont une idée mais
aura aussi un espace pour ceux qui
voudront faire assez vu il y aura un
espace pour ceux qui voudront préparer
un entretien il y aura un espace pour
ceux qui voudront savoir quelle
orientation quel ou aller
professionnellement demain et qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire maintenant un espace
des moyens technologiques de l'énergie
ça suffit pas parce que ces jeunes là il
faut leur tendre la main ces jeunes là
il faut les former ces jeunes là il faut
leur montrer des exemples
et alors
tout seul ou avec les donateurs qui se
sont bien qu'ils ont bien voulu se
mettre autour de deux projets il ya un
éminent donateurs ici patrice bergamini
et je voudrais remercier l'union
européenne d'avoir été le premier
contributeur à se mettre derrière ce
projet eh ben il ya besoin même pas
quelque chose que même patrice peut pas
faire c'est quoi c'est vous nous avons
alors mon mon anglais n'est pas encore
parfait comme vous pouvez le constater
nous avons besoin de gens qui viennent
qui disent voilà j'ai fait telle
orientation
voilà ce que ça a donné on a besoin de
gens qui disent nous avons vécu une
telle expérience
voilà ce que ça fait nous avons besoin
d'artistes nous avons besoin
d'entrepreneurs
nous avons besoin de musiciens qui
viennent parler à ces jeunes qui
viennent servir d'exemples qui viennent
tendre la main et sans cet effort
collectif ce projet là sera juste un
bâtiment de plus dans la géographie
alors ce sera un peu un beau bâtiment
assez diana - sidi bouzid qui on manque
crucialement mais ça sera juste un
bâtiment et donc je fais je profite de
ce passage pour faire un appel solennel
à toutes et à tous pour que ont plus
changé la donne et qu'on puisse donner
de l'espoir et pas seulement de l'espoir
que concrètement on puisse changer les
choses donc nous avons besoin de vous
volontaire nous avons besoin de demain
nous avons besoin de cerveaux nous avons
besoin de formateurs nous avons besoin
de gens qui croient que dans ce pays
ils peuvent changer le monde la
démocratie c'est quelque chose qui est
la prise de pouvoir des citoyens
la prise de pouvoir des citoyens ce
n'est pas tous les cinq ans à mettre un
papier dans une urne
la prise de pouvoir des citoyens c'est
que tous ont soit responsable de ce pays
la prise de pouvoir des citoyens ça veut
dire que chacun d'entre nous se disent à
côté de chez chat à côté de la plage à
côté des loisirs à côté d'eux des
vacances à côté du match de foot de jeu
c'est bly qui est contre je sais plus
qui je pourrai dans mon agent va faire
de la place à mes concitoyens faire de
la place à ceux qui en ont besoin
faire de la place à ceux qui manquent
tout est ma contribution peut changer
radicalement leur vie pour terminer je
voudrais vous raconter une petite
histoire il ya vingt ans quand j'ai
démarré dans la ce qu'on appelle la
philanthropie
j'ai entendu un monsieur raconter une
histoire et dire qu'après une marée il y
avait des millions des toiles de mer qui
séchait sur la plage est un vieux étant
avec une cam était en train de ramasser
difficilement une et la remettre
alors qu'il ya des millions à 15 jeunes
qui faisait son footing jeudi habitait
foug regard des millions des toiles qui
sont là ton action ne changera rien pour
la plage dans sa totalité et le vieux
répondent oui mais pour celle que je
remets dans l'eau ça changera tout je
voudrais que vous changez tout pour ce
que vous avez aidé merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]